[Applause]
let say hello a mighty day
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody D I like your outfit thank you
you two yeah nice R okay so you have me
on with an icon telling awesome Elvis
stories I know what are you bringing to
the table
nothing nothing no I have to ask this
though because I'm new to the building I
love working here it's awesome yeah
welcome yes so do you love it do you
have like your favorite places I uh it's
fun seeing NBC like newscasters in the
lobby I've seen Lester Holt just walk in
jeans which is which trips you out
you're like you don't own
jeans we're born in a suit so Rachel
mattow I've seen the Starbucks um down
below I know that Starbucks the subway
Starbucks right yes the subway Starbucks
have you ever been in there like really
early had a early call time it was like
6 something a.m. they were Blas in music
I was like like it was like a
rave and you're like I looked at these
two and I was like it's 6: a.m. bro bro
I was like it's like that's was it Kelly
Clarkson music no not even I'm not going
it's your music or nothing your music or
nothing it was actually good people wa a
lifetime For a Moment Like This I would
have been more AC I watched that and
almost cried oh I did cry well I was
like Kelly deserves it so
much Kell's a star thank you I was I
remember I was in College I was I was
just telling her the first season of
idol um our they have a person every
week too and ours was Bert backrack that
came on that week yeah and we did BT
back Rag songs I did Walk On By before
DOA before DOA that's right I don't know
if she was alive I'm a lot older than
her um so wait I've I've been on SNL and
I I will say the most upsetting thing
for me to watch is I'm there all day
right even as a musical guest you're
there all day right and and you watch
all these skits get cut oh yeah so like
what in like funny ones like sometimes
y'all will keep some and I'm like why'd
you keep that one over that one I'm like
I was like that yeah I was like why' you
cut that yeah so has a great one that
you loved ever been cut um I mean yeah a
lot of stuff's been cut over the years
sometimes you'll put one up at the table
read where they choose what'll go to
dress rehearsal that never get picked we
it was around Christmas time and we
wrote this was years back while when
Trump was still president at the time
and it was
was I was hesitant to even bring it
up I just heard I heard it was just a
sound I heard a sound I'm like yep I
know I know exactly sound from the gut
but it was that's so
funny I just heard it I'm like why did I
even bring it up um so wait so that's
happening there's a lot of material
there though for SNL it was a home alone
and Eric Trump was left home alone in
Trump
Tower and so don Jr had to go back and I
got to get back to New York Eric's home
alone and there were like investigators
coming in in place of the how did this
get cut I know well it didn't even get
picked so it didn't even make it to the
place where it could be cut but all of
Eric's traps didn't work he was like
hosing down the carpet and we were a
little bummed cuz you know obviously
home alone's a classic so it is a
classic you know there's every week
there's stuff I know I just noticed I
was like man they get rid of some funny
stuff sometimes yeah you got to come
host oh my God Fant and do
music Here's the thing I don't think I'm
funny like that you'd be awesome like I
can be witty at times like just talking
but I don't think I'm funny like that I
did do a couple skids one time though um
when I went to sing there it was with
Horatio oh what's hard for me is I laugh
like y'all no it's not no it's not
you're supposed to act you're supposed
to like stay in character but like yeah
I don't know how any of y'all held it
down I don't know if y'all saw Pedro
Pascal when he was in the hospital oh my
God my pants watching that like how did
y'all not and they're you're all looking
at him like like yeah and and I was like
how are they not laughing right I mean
sometimes sometimes there'll be sketches
and the camera will be on you and then
you'll try to keep it together and then
when the camera's on someone else you'll
start laughing like especially screw
them I know with someone like Pedro who
was so good oh my God but I think you
would be fantastic you very nice me very
nice well it's time for another
commercial break everybody Saturday
Night Live returns this weekend you can
watch on NBC and peacock we've got a
touching
[Music]
story
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home